what are your thoughts on the the dean
Phillips effort well let me start
ecumenically and say I've I've been
telling Democrats who would listen for
years that they need to build a a
younger bench and that was true in
Congress I was supportive of Tim Ryan's
effort to to S you know push Nancy
Pelosi aside and get some younger blood
into Democratic Leadership because not
only is it necessary inside the party
but then you grow a bench you condition
Democratic voters to see new people they
haven't seen a new face in
Forever you know not since Barack Obama
came along you know they they really
just like to keep putting the same
people into these positions so
ecumenically I love this I love wait
let's summarize
Barack Hillary Joe Joe yeah you're right
yeah yeah and listen before Trump we did
the same thing we decided who was going
to be the next nominee at the last
election right like whose turn was it
who came in second we'll put them up and
so we didn't you know we didn't give
voters a a a a chance to um you know
find new Talent really either so that's
that's ecumenically I love this um
idea you know
practically it's a long shot I'm sure
you know this and and um I'm sure I
haven't met Dean Phillips I I I might
have I might have interviewed him at
some point um he seems lovely and really
smart and I I like his brand of of
politics and I think he could do well in
New Hampshire but it's really hard to go
against an incumbent you know this um
because you have the full weight and
resources of the DNC or the RNC behind
you it's just really hard to sort of
jostle that you know infrastructure
loose and cut through it but listen I I
have nothing against Joe personally and
I will vote for him if Trump is the
nominee but I would love to see someone
new come along from either party I think
our parties are broken and we can see
from polling that most people agree
about 65% of Americans do not feel
aligned with either of the two parties
and that's because they're in the middle
on almost every issue the parties like
to talk in extremes and so you can feel
very unrepresented if you are in the
middle in fact the major aity uh on lots
of issues from abortion to immigration
to guns to climate if you're in the
middle you feel orphaned by your party
because you're not pure enough you're
not you're not you know loyal enough um
that's very I think um disorienting for
a lot of Voters and they're deeply
deeply disillusioned with our two
parties and they don't want either of
these guys they don't want to make this
Choice yeah the Biden Trump rematch is
unappealing to three out of four
Americans or something ridiculous
and it really puts the dysfunction of
the parties in Stark relief I'm with you
on trying to upgrade generationally um I
I also agree you know the party um has
it out for you uh it's tough um so with
with Dean's campaign let's say he puts
up a big number in New Hampshire yeah
and then the Press looks at it and it's
like wow like that that because I think
even people who are very deeply in the
know would be shocked and stunned if
Dean put up 25 % or whatever the number
is uh uh and then uh the question is
whether you get a genuine horse race
Dynamic um South Carolina happens um 10
days later it'd be tough um but Michigan
Michigan is at the end of February and
that could be a real contest especially
because there's a lot of discontent with
Joe uh in Michigan uh in in various
quarters but do you worry that let's say
he does well in New Hampshire you worry
that Biden and plenty of folks in the
media will just say well Biden wasn't
there he wasn't on the
ballot yeah I mean they're going to try
and minimize the impact of the loss for
sure um but you are looking at an
environment where the incumbent
president traditionally will get you
know 85 90% um with zero effort at all
yeah and you also have an historical
precedent of I think it was Hubert
Humphrey challenging uh LBJ and getting
42% in New then LBJ said I'm
out afterwards um so there's this whole
range I mean gosh if Dean were to get
42% uh everyone would look at that and
say I mean like like this is a
repudiation of the Biden plan um and I
do think the Biden plan is a terrible
plan I think that as in the running
Biden I don't I'm not talking about a
specific policy I'm talking the Biden
plan to run for re-election a second
time I mean if he were to do a George
Washington and say hey I'm I'm I'm out
time to pass the torch to the Next
Generation he would go down in the books
as one of the
greats Trump gets a lot of great things
done is a voice of reason on the world
stage and then steps aside of the Next
Generation that's like check check check
as it is instead it's going to be
overstay welcome uh in like serve the
country back to Trump uh you know on a
platter um and then bone the end of
democracy I
mean that that that's where we're
heading in my estimation
he's sort of Brett faving it right I
mean overstaying a little bit too much
for that last season with the Jets which
didn't really work out um and this was
so unnecessary because he was elected to
be a transitional he even called himself
I'm gonna be a bridge to the Next
Generation and my my joke was like right
bridge to the next generation is not
cling to office until you expire at the
age of 86 I mean that's nuts exactly and
yeah the there should be no
embarrassment among Democrats that they
want to move on from Joe Biden the idea
was him for him to get out get Trump out
get some sanity restored which he did
check check check and then yeah leave it
to the next Democrat in line of of your
choosing right so there should be no
embarrassment about that but they are so
unwilling to admit that it's his time to
go and move on they won't do it they
can't do it and it might end up you know
handing the country back over to Trump
hey YouTube thanks for watching please
do hit like And subscribe and hit that
Bell if you want to be notified every
time a new episode drops thank
you